as d'marie Carroll takes control 6g
looking for constituency still avert
coming along the Beast by slamming
examine the Vics want to talk to Brooks
his way inside blocks the hook drives
that's what a way to trade beyond Graham
now DeAngelo Russell dishes to levert
jump stop deep dish and he finds tamari
Carol for the deuce the first was a
bribe gets to the rack scoops and scores
Julia called for the foul now it's 13 2
for George after not being able to hit
anything now they're hitting everything
Leonard just put Dudley on skates for a
moment good anticipation by little
pushes it down with two hands and with
understand if they are all players that
can play off the ball as well puts down
his ability to kind of graze up against
you as a defender seven-foot wingspan
he's 6 foot 9 215 pounds back to back
love hurt bottom 2 3 Drummond poked away
by Russell on a steal
Russell gives it back loafer skies high
for the jam heads-up play by Russell
side Levert high screen ellen the cross
the cab the deuce
caris love hurt very Drummond on the
bench right now there's a little bit of
foul trouble we have not seen Kenneth to
read we have not seen John and Musa Dagh
leaves it in and a foul Lebert he gets a
switch now trio comes back labert count
it the strength and one Jairus levert
with a chance for three Nets looking for
the win the Burke makes his move drives
in let's go in front by two and it goes
back again it is not always easy to get
your timing right when you're looking to
take the last shot getting defense from
the Pacers shot clock is down to four
levert will take and take now they'll
take that Creek muscling into Dudley
stands there by Laverne men to save what
a play from cara's levert can did when
he catch it he done and off they go to
the races
Beauty I had a conversation with Jarrett
before the game the Slam by Alan what a
setup I lover oh what a great pass and
the lefty finish big fella
he draws Nance Lebert shimmy spin tip it
[ __ ] it
big time highlight so when you're going
against the big you try and get a couple
of aches you try and do something but
sometimes bigs can help you make a shot
cuz you know you have to shoot up over
Russell mismatch with Davis
that means Alan has the smaller patient
levert the drives up bump left hand and
a chance at a three-point play
right and Holliday you see didn't have a
good angle to get it into Jared Allen
but realize that Anthony Davis was
pulled out from the basket so it allowed
that open space there in the middle of
the lane levert goes to works uses his
bodily there's been plenty of movement
off the ball as well Spencer Dinwiddie
in fact door you see here Karis Evert
setting up Jared Allen with the
beautiful delivery labert look at her
shake Jones takes a baseline but today
alright Cara's love Burt Lebert cookies
takes it right away from Griffin the end
of his dribbles his first go back to the
steal by teres lefur gets it ahead and
then D'Angelo Russell embraces the
contact bodies up the Coogee look tied
at 18 marquise Chris in for Houston the
dribble drive Hey but a push watch that
I mean totally crosses up Eric Gordon
slices through someone you don't want to
leave wide open tonight
it's Anthony five of eleven for three
cherish love her from downtown wide-open
levert Russell did see him at first
caliber go drive flip an incredible move
all eight of the best points have come
in the paint
Lavar on attack on two more he dies
great job just going at the big
fellowship out you're gonna be all right
clock winding down the board has to make
it happen straightaway hurt one touch
from the outside Booker
denied Karis lover sticking with Booker
shot we talked about him finishing with
his left hander
oh that Egor Kokoschka shared with
Lindsey Smith half sideways the lack of
energy as Levert did for Bucky attacking
yoga JH n one Harris the verse will go
to the line with a chance for the
three-point play force now to make a
move down to four there's a lot of time
the bird David glance carries Laverne
there's point three on the clock
OD wise the ball in his hand he has got
Harris smothering him and still gets
around him gets to his fabulous app and
what you'd like it to have no time left
on the clock I mean point three seconds
excellent timing by Karis levert off of
this play and you see the quickness that
crossover is what had Harris reaching
and the ability to get around him first
five games they were last with over
night time
seven to shoot
Russell great walk in love Bert throws
it down then this goes back with a
special delivery by D'Angelo Russell
right over the top tube at cutting Karis
levert Isum
you can see him great job lose these
Timberwolves players on this end look
Kurt gets wickets on his hip dances his
way to two since switched on him
eight to shoot wants it back for Burt
look at it take gifts it goes right
around if to the rack two-hand flush yo
the offensive board at a reload for
Chicago cut by Harrison wants the ball
Levert takes it away levert surveys
Carroll fires got it ten turnovers for
the Bulls done lost his footing
intercepted levert up the floor
Russell try to get the angle the
hesitation any time to work with on the
shot clocks ball reversal
ananova zigzags
cram ahead of the field with Leonard
there no problem my pleasure
up ahead night tapped it over the
hollis-jefferson I had a big bucket of
fries also here second round Harris a
three these got it Levert one-on-one
with Sexton Lebert he got bumped there
by digits no call that he gets the
bucket with three seconds Walker it's
gonna have to hoist Walker stripping
over did they call a foul they do not
game over
Brooklyn wins it 117 115 the final
dissolve up as if to indicate foul on
the left look but no foul calls
Charlotte seven school Lebert oh nice
straight to get around cellar riches
give stuff Williams on the drive feeding
it off to the devil detective Oliver tap
an excellent job protecting the reap
[Applause]
amount of time that he was out not able
to be on the floor three bucks a long
time nice look there purple of burden
Allen finishes it
his vision didn't go anywhere
particularly close clutch games they
played this year
even if that eight game losing streak
they rolling last second heart-wrenching
losses levert he's got the lengthy maker
Carroll fires got it three hearts to
tighten up it starts to get a key and
let's not take any chances
God make her the Miss cherish love
Burton to the cup so here's the screen
the back screen against Smith and then
it's too late for banker just too fast
we both came back from the 40 odd games
that he missed due to injury he was a
starter but he's working better off the
bench finding his rhythm and in rhythm
there Karras love hurt with the bucket
chicken he had a lot of injuries in
college and him right now this is just a
great dribble drive shoot up that knee
injury that he suffered in this late in
his career Florida recovered from that
rapport
Oh from teeth and the lead is back down
to three points sometimes they over
dribble and then this is just I'm over
dribbling the time is going down and
then you luck out
just like a bear try to trip over
instead of Thomas Jefferson hits the
back convincing it's the three levert
hips evolve and he finishes at the cup
Hale Bacharach's taking us on like I
said earlier the gift they can go at Gap
levert the crossover into the lane nice
look terrible pun ex from three great
basketball but on the floor right now
for Portland they've done a nice job
levert jumps it saves it steals it
beautifully done one of feed in winning
a Carroll for the layup and the foul
Dinwiddie spins on Fraser gets around
him labert nice taps for Carroll who
fills it up another one right at the rim
Carroll gives it up levert corner jump
is smoking hot
great job great throw ahead way to hold
them up
it's a slippery ground trying to stick
with them
gets possession sets it up for
karenallen in the throw flush labert
one-on-one with ground spin fade carries
Wilfred went to 22 to go
laverne on a switch takes it around
Illya Silva for the tubes you've got
such a quick first step it's Russell
Wilson shucks off down to four levert
fires got a 3-carat Levert delivers
offensive glass has been an area where
they're picking up so many extra
possessions and gain a lot of momentum
Graham with the crank and look at this
play just a beautiful job by Karis
Lebert coming off that stack goes right
at me it didn't go that way did it
levert turns the corner on Jones
what vertical look at how quickly he
rises up throws it down
ah that is not love I'd be interested to
know from staring
you know what's that life is a coach
when you're coming back close I say get
another travel to space and driving good
time at Ohio State they played Michigan
áwhat levert played for Michigan here's
a free Wow nice shot
Terrace Wofford and out of bounds ago
cheers levert moments ago he's got all
six of the next once make it eight in
the corner and his first thought is a
sixer turned back that's with that
ragged offensive start but it has been
Karras levert Greg giving them a shot
the arm off the bench at the
Indianapolis up to over there plums
levert comes around the spray pump it
down and he's fouled over beau bond here
watch I creates that space there and in
little flick on the elbow and it just
picked up his first personal foul
ever at dawn as he climbs the way what a
beautiful set up during the ran an
out-of-bounds agos moments ago levert
attacking mb in slow rotation and just
throw it to the rim
look at this finish here by our
[Music]
Vinson Dudley right now here's the dump
I love bird right over Joelle MV because
conditioning and rhythm are real
concerns to him he says Vikings
going and doing much they are very
focused on JoEllen beads eating and diet
as well and be behind the back pass
early success here these young men 2020
minutes Jefferson
[Music]
[Applause]
yes sir
by the two seconds it comes Nagar to the
rack and a tough floater we attract it
to take us to the end of the first [ __ ]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content